so hello uh welcome to 229 uh so we're
starting a block of three lectures that
I get the privilege of of spending some
time with you and kind of walking you
through the building blocks and Basics
before I get into the plan for those
three lectures I want to make sure we
understand a couple of logistics so I I
posted something on Ed that kind of
explained why I was setting up lecture
in the way I am you are not obligated to
read that but if you're interested go
ahead and read it super happy to take
feedback and discuss any of that
one of the things that I liked about the
pandemic was that more people were
asking questions during class and I
think part of that was because people
were you know using the anonymous
feature on Zoom quite a bit and I and I
wish we still had that we don't in this
class for various reasons so what we're
going to do instead is we're going to
have this Ed thread that I just set up
that says lecture two 330 in class
question thread and feel free to fire
away questions on there I may not take
all them I reserve the right to skip
them Tas May jump in and answer some
um and I'll try to follow up on anything
that's there but it's really helpful to
me that that you ask questions and happy
to talk about whatever you want uh
really be relevant to the class is
helpful but like pretty much whatever
you want
um
second thing there are a couple of
downloads that I put up before my
lectures I put up two things one is a
handwritten note of what I'm going to
talk about which are the same notes that
I use I modify them a little bit and
then also a template in case you want to
follow along again you don't need any of
this stuff you can just sit watch it on
video watch it here ask questions do
whatever you want but it's just so that
you know the material that's there and
that you know things like data that I
want to show you and look real I can cut
and paste that in and you can have it in
front of you while I go through it okay
all right so that's the logistics I will
use I'm going to try and use the iPad I
like using the Whiteboard feel so this
is a good compromise because it slows me
down if I get excited I'll start talking
all kinds of nonsense so this will focus
me a little bit more on the class and
you'll see how long I last all right so
what we're going to do in this first
three sections of the class first three
lectures is kind of build up uh
increasingly sophisticated machine
learning models and your what you're
going to see is that they are very very
similar to a model that you probably
already know and love which is linear
regression if you don't know linear
regression don't worry today's lecture
is effectively going to be talking about
linear regression with slightly fancier
notation and you know some little bits
around the algorithm but it's basically
just fitting a line okay it's it's
really hopefully going to be something
that you've seen and you can grab onto
and then what we'll do in the next
lecture is we'll generalize this from
regression which is the kind of
traditional fitting align to
classification now I have a couple of
twists
we choose our notation a little bit
carefully and what that allows us to do
is show that that way that we're looking
at classification and we'll talk about
what classification really is allows us
to do a much larger class of models
which are called these exponential
family of models and they're going to
kind of rear their head throughout the
course so we're going to see a precise
definition that allows us to have a huge
number of statistical models and kind of
treat them in one way so we don't have
to understand the details of every
little model we have an abstraction of
how to find its parameters how to do
inference on it let's get a prediction
out of it and kind of understand it and
kind of understand these algorithms I'll
try to highlight for you as we go
through there which of these pieces
actually carry over to what I would call
kind of modern or industrial machine
learning feel free to ask questions
effectively the way we solve these
algorithms or what we solve these
underlying optimization problems is
exactly the way we run everything from
how images are detected to how you know
search works in various different
corners of it to natural language
processing to translation weirdly enough
this abstraction kind of carries over
for all of that and the underlying
Workhorse algorithm which we'll see is
called stochastic gradient descent and
so we'll try and introduce it in that
absolutely simplest setting okay and so
that's the idea it's going to be
building parallel structure for the next
kind of three so linear regression
classification and then we're going to
go through this generalized exponential
family and they will have a very
parallel structure if you go back to the
notes you'll be able to pull out like oh
this is the solving part this is the
model part and what we're going to do
there
all right then tangyu takes over teaches
you a bunch of awesome stuff neural nets
all the rest of that stuff kernels then
I come back and teach you unsupervised
and there again is a different structure
there but it's very very similar and
graphical models and the rest make it
make an appearance there okay so today
our plan is to get through first just
some very basic definitions
um we'll be a little bit pedantic there
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't ask
questions means if you don't understand
something you should and I haven't done
my job so just fire off a question in
any form you like then we're going to
talk about linear regression which as I
said is is fitting a line except we'll
be fitting High dimensional lines
eventually so we're going to want to
abstract that away we'll talk about
batch and stochastic gradient descent
which are two algorithms and machine
learning as tangyu talked about we're
not great with terminology this
algorithm is called incremental gradient
descent in the 60s it's been around
forever our incremental gradient methods
actually it wasn't even it's not even a
descent method formally doesn't matter
the point is these are old things that
people have been using for a long time
and weirdly enough it's what we use
every day like it's as I said this is
like a Workhorse algorithm that you're
going to see and then I'll very briefly
cover the normal equation because I
think it's a curse on your homeworks
um you know and it's like you know also
gives you some practice with Vector
derivative so you do need to know the
vector derivatives stuff to make your
life easier in this class you'll have to
compute occasionally compute a gradient
or compute a derivative and this is a
place where you kind of know what the
right answer is so when you compute
these derivatives like you know it's an
easy place to check yourself but I
wouldn't say that like normal equations
are like the most important thing you'll
learn in this class it's just you know
it's all you should know what they are
it's not hard okay
all right great
so let's talk about supervised learning
all right so this next section as I
mentioned is going to be all supervised
learning and it'll all follow kind of
the same general schema
right and what I mean is we're going to
try and have some what we call
prediction function
and basically all that's going to be is
a function H which will use this
notation consistently that goes from
some set X to some set y okay before
defining this formally let me just give
you a couple of examples so one idea is
that X could be the set some set of
images
right so we can look at in images a
bunch of images and we could ask does it
contain a cat right that was actually
like a very important machine learning
problem at kind of one point in time
people still work on that right you know
what's the object that's in this image
that would be a prediction right we are
wise here would be a set of labels that
say things like cat dog things like that
all right
it could also be text
right so we could look at text here and
we could ask questions you know that you
know maybe we arguably should be better
on in machine learning like is it hate
speech
all right
right and so we ask here you know this x
here these are all examples of data
types that we want to work on
and these are all labels or y's that
we're talking about okay now we'll look
at as tangyu showed in his lecture we'll
look at house data now historically
house data has been one of the most
common machine learning and statistical
uh tasks it's in like every stats 101
course so you may have seen this before
I kind of hoped you have
um and when we look through it we're
gonna I'm gonna point out the real data
that you can use to try this out in a
competition like kaggle there's a kaggle
where you can download house prices from
Ames Iowa and try and guess how much
they you know how much they should sell
for things like that right people
actually make money on that by the way
right not everybody sometimes hard if
you followed the news right Zillow tried
to sell houses and estimate them and
flip them and they lost a bunch of money
Blackstone if you care about private
Equity I managed to make money doing
that right they bought houses and they
were able to predict how much they were
going to sell them at so this may be
trivial as it seems
um is there actually problems that
people care about okay anyway
so we need an abstraction so we have
this X and we have this y we need
something else to make this a supervised
problem and we talked about it yesterday
we're given a training set
okay
so what is a training set
well formally it's just going to be a
set of pairs this is just introducing
notation
you have an X1 and a y1
okay
now
comma all the way x n to y n
all right
all right now x i here is going to live
in x
it's summing coding of an image maybe
it's the bits that are in the image that
would be a reasonable encoding maybe
it's RGB values that's in there if it's
text maybe it's the ASCII characters or
Unicode characters that are in there
it's some bag of bits okay now we're
later going to abstract this away and
almost always work in a vector space
we'll talk about where those Vector
spaces come from but that that's kind of
where the the data actually lives and y
i is going to live in some set those are
going to be our labels oops
right so now our do given that
information
is we have to find
a good age
X to Y okay
and we'll call often we call it h
because it's a hypothesis
all right
all right now
that notion of good is going to occupy a
fair amount of what we worry about over
the next couple of lectures what does it
mean to be good right in some intuitive
sense because I have these examples of
x's and y's one reasonable thing I
should expect is I I kind of get them
more often right than random chance
right that's like kind of a very basic
idea of what would be good you show me
an image it has a cat in it I get most
of the cats right now you've used enough
machine learning to know like we don't
get it right all the time right and it's
still useful so we'll have statistical
Notions we'll try to get it right kind
of uh you know on average now more
advanced things like just recency biased
because Tatsu was talking about it in
the class before on the board you could
also worry about how well you do on some
groups versus other groups some groups
you know you're predicting really well
on but other groups have qualities and
you're not predicting as well on them
you could worry about that and say I
want to do my prediction I only care
about is being you know as well as I do
on any one of these predefined groups
okay so you could have multiple Notions
of good we're going to stick with the
simplest and basic which is like how
accurate am I at the task in this okay
but this mathematical framework can
accommodate all of those like when you
actually write it down the tweaks that I
just mentioned to come up with those uh
different what they're called loss
functions is really really kind of
straightforward mathematically they'll
kind of go through the same thing okay
so all I want you to take away from this
is we have a training set that's what's
provided to us these y eyes are going to
be supervision they're in some set
our goal will be to find a good h among
all the possible functions and by the
way the class of functions from like one
space to another is enormous right so
we're going to have to restrict that in
some way
and that's kind of the setup for
supervised learning okay
right now this here we will often refer
to as the training set or the training
data that's there and what we're really
interested by the way in which is
probably a little bit counterintuitive
the first time you hear it is we're not
doing strictly machine Learners we're
not doing strictly what's called
interpolation we're not just trying to
predict back on the X and Y pairs that
we have
we're going to try and worry about how
well we're going to do on a new X and a
new y so why does that make sense
imagine someone shows up with an image
odds of that like you know they just
took it with their phone right my phone
is just littered with pictures of my
daughters okay so if I take a new
picture of my daughter and probably the
label should be the same as the last
thousand pictures I took but it's going
to look a little different right so when
I show that that picture I don't care
how well I did on the last picture that
I took over I care how well I did on
this picture right on that on those X
and Y Pairs and that's a little bit
weird and that means that implicitly
what we're going to assume here is that
these x's and y's you should think about
is drawn from a large population of
images right that are out there and we
want to do not we were sampling some
piece of it and we want to do well on
those images that are going to come in
the future that's why we think about it
as a prediction so it may not be great
to just return the label of every X and
Y we've ever seen right we have to in
some way kind of generalize is the
technical term to those new images okay
all right so the reason we call this a
prediction is we care about new X's
that are not in our training set
right
now if you look at that and you're
mathematically minded you're like how
the heck did you say anything about that
and hopefully you got a clue there if
you don't if it doesn't make sense yet
don't worry we're going to make some
assumption like we randomly sampled from
all of the images and how well do I do
on another randomly chosed image okay
that's what we're going to do
in some way the set you train on though
better be like the set that you evaluate
on that you take your predictions on or
you're out of luck if you train your
model on pictures of my daughter and ask
to know about cars
I don't know how it's going to do right
so there's clearly some link here okay
now weirdly enough although I say that
one of the big trends in machine
learning that's going on right now in
fact of course that I co-taught with
Tatsu and Percy last quarter was about
these large models that we just trained
to predict kind of everything that's on
the web and they seem to do pretty well
on things okay so just want to highlight
like it's there's a really strange
notion of good you spend your whole life
trying to think what good is if you're a
machine learner okay a couple more
things as I said I'm just going to go
off on tangents if no one stops me all
right so if Y is discrete this is just
terminology
so it's a discrete space we think about
this as classification
okay that's the terminology you could
think the simplest version is yes or no
does it contain a cat yes or no binary
classification
you could also have a bunch of different
classes is it a car a plane a truck what
model of car is it those are
classifications they're enumerated sets
the other thing which you're probably
familiar with from you know calculus and
we'll talk a little bit about today is
when Y is continuous
and this is called regression
so this is an example of something
that's discrete this cat
yeah and the house price this is going
to be an example of regression and
that's what we're going to look at today
in lecture three we switch and we start
to look at classification which has some
subtle differences
okay awesome
all right let's look at some data any
questions about the setup or or kind of
higher level questions about what it is
what goes on here
all right sounds good
okay so let's look at some some real
data here I'll try and get it all on the
screen so I'm going to look at this
house price data as I mentioned this is
the Ames data set which follows a very
famous data set just for historical
reasons of Boston house prices that you
can go look at and download you can
download in one line into pandas if you
want happy to put uh you know
information online about how to do that
this is real data of real houses and
Ames and so what I'm showing here is
like these are their real IDs I just
randomly selected some to kind of make
the picture pretty right just be honest
and then here's their sale price right
so this is their actual sale price and
the data and this is their lot area this
is kind of like some notion of square
feet that's actually present this data
set I think has something like 93 or
columns inside of it I've just selected
a small set of them we'll come back to
that in a second
now one of the things that I did here is
like the first thing you should do when
you're encountering a new set of data
and I cannot emphasize this enough is
look at it the number of times that like
people especially engineers in Industry
like take their data and like start
running fancy stuff on it I'm like well
did you did you look I still remember
when I was running a machine learning
team at an unnamed large company and
they're like why are you sitting in the
cafe just like labeling data just like
looking at data sets for like days it's
like I don't know what's going on I want
to figure out what's actually what
people are actually doing on this data
set and it's it's really important okay
so when you're doing your projects like
first plot it so here's a plot right
x-axis square feet y-axis price and
clearly there's some like General upward
trajectory Trend here we're going to be
more precise about that in the next
slide right you get bigger houses they
cost maybe as you can think about it
you're like that's not quite true like
if it's in a really desirable
neighborhood
um like you know costs more and if it's
in a less desirable neighborhood maybe
it costs less so they're clearly other
factors those are gonna be called
features in a minute but this is our
first model okay so let's look at one
other feature
so we can also look at the number of
bedrooms right so you see here a plot
these are categorical values that's why
I put them in there I mean they're kind
of continuous in some way you can still
treat them as numbers so that's fine you
see there's some spread you know among
three bedrooms and among four bedrooms
and the price is the waxes
so what do we want here going back up
for a second what do we want actually we
want to get a function what's our
hypothesis go from it goes from lot area
and it predicts price okay that's just
notation okay this is what we're after
okay so you show me this data
and my goal is to produce some age okay
now they talked about there are lots of
functions that could take in you know a
lot areas and return sale prices it
could scramble it it could do whatever
it wanted it could you know go look up
from an oracle whatever I wanted to do
there are tons and tons of functions
we're going to look at a simple
restricted class of functions in just a
second okay but I just want to put that
in your hand like this is actually a
pretty hard problem
so we need some some representation for
H okay so how do we represent that age
now we're going to look at a class of
models which is called linear although
if you're a stickler you'll realize
right away that they're affine I'll
explain why I allow myself to cheat like
that in a second
okay so here's a here's a model that we
could use
okay
okay so the idea here is
you give me the variable right X1 which
in this case would be like the square
footage or of whatever you have and then
I will multiply it by some Theta and
this Theta is going to be a weight we'll
call it or a parameter of the model and
this is how I'm going to form my
regression okay looks like a line
right
so far so good right
now let's see if I can show you a line
there's a line that does it okay okay
this is that's basically that line
through the data that we just looked at
okay
now
I want to actually come one in one more
second how does this actually map onto
this oops scroll down sorry for the bad
scrolling here I'm going to go to zero
remember my H is going to look like x
equals Theta 0 plus Theta 1 X1 well what
does it look like just so you make sure
the picture is clear this here is Theta
0 right it's where I am it's a response
at zero and then this gives me the slope
right this is the of slope Theta 1. okay
and then when I go to predict what do I
do I grab a point let's grab this one
I project its value onto the X and this
is where I predict its price would be
right this is the price of this one
does that make sense
okay all right awesome
okay so this looks like a relatively
simple model but if you look at it like
you know at this scale not so bad
honestly right there's some kind of
linear Trend there there's some errors
or what we call residuals in a second
we'll try and minimize those these
errors
but this is this is like our first
predictive model okay and as I said it's
something that you're hopefully quite
familiar with just in kind of fancier
notation for the moment
all right awesome
okay so now I'm going to go
sorry for the skipping I'm going to go
and say okay how do we generalize this
right so imagine we had our data set
we had X1 X2 so on and we have a bunch
of features and I'm going to use my
features for my notes but hopefully this
doesn't cause you any panic I have size
I have bedroom
lot size and as I mentioned in the
actual real data set there's like 80 90
of these things and have price okay
okay and remember price is my
Target this is my why and these are my
x's so this is uh you know I'm just
going to put numbers here don't worry
about them I don't know why I wrote
These in my notes but these are the ones
I used just for the sake of consistency
so write these 45k
30k
400 900 doesn't matter too much okay the
thing that I that I care about
is that this is my notation for the
first data point in the second data
point and this is X11 this is X12 this
is the second feature okay
right now
I called this a linear model right but
if you're a stickler and you took a
bunch of things you're like no it's an
affine model you have this you know
Theta 0 hanging out there the way that
we get around that is we're going to
assume that Theta 0 for every model x0
for every model is identically one okay
so that's just a convention don't stub
your toe on it that is x i
zero equals one
and I claim you should convince yourself
for one second that means that what is
linear in this new set of features
is my old affine models right and I just
put I'm just putting a one here every
place
okay
all right that allows me to just
simplify my notation okay
so what's my what's what's the model the
class of models that I'm looking at here
well they're linear models again with
that terminology and they're going to
look at Theta zero times you know x0
which we know is one plus Theta 1 times
X1 Plus
data and I'm going to call it D times XD
okay
and this equals
sum J goes from zero to D
Theta J times x j
all right and remember I'm just going to
write it again
x0 equals one
and NB means you know no well none okay
all right
now
this allows me now I have a very high
dimensional problem now High Dimensions
don't work like low Dimensions I won't
go into a whole thing about it but High
dimensions are very fun and interesting
spaces okay you can you can build really
interesting machine learning models by
taking your data doing what's called
embedding it and then training a linear
model on top and that actually in some
areas is actually state of the art of
what we know how to do so those models
have potentially you know hundreds of
features that are underneath the covers
for us these features right now are
going to be all human interpretable
they're going to come from the table so
when you give me a the row X1 I fill in
the value this value here with 2104
I fill in this you know the X2 value and
so on
and as I go okay so I just fill in the
values as I go that's how I form my
prediction
okay a little bit more notation
right now if you don't remember I'm just
going to introduce Vector notation here
these are column vectors they're going
to look like this and this is just going
to save me time and space and you know
fill the things
okay X1 is going to be a vector 2.
with X11
X2 X12
so on oop sorry
about that I wanted to start at zero
x 1 0 x 1 1 and so on and remember
this thing is one which we've said many
times and this is whatever the value is
up there 2104 okay in general this is
going to be the size feature
the bedrooms feature
and so on
clear enough right these are the
parameters
and these are the features
all right so why be so pedantic about
this piece it's because we're going to
use this in several different guises
these parameters are going to mean
different things as we change the
hypothesis function over time
and we just want to make sure the
mapping is clear so just make sure the
mapping is super crystal clear in your
head of how I take a data point that
looks like this and map it into a
feature Vector that looks like that
that's all that I care that you get out
of this and then we have some different
vectors
and y i is going to be the price in our
example
is price
okay
now recall this notion wasn't we didn't
pick this by accident
this was a training example this pair x
i y i is a training example
this is the ice training example
right just the iPhone and the set
okay so far so good
now I'm going to create a matrix here
capital X
that's going to have
one row
for every example oops
so on X
so there are n of those characters by my
notation
and so where does this Matrix live
well there are n rows and recall because
of my convention that I added a extra
Dimension which I always made one it's D
plus one and I'm just highlighting this
and being pedanta because I don't want
it to bite you when you realize like why
they have D plus 1 where did it come
from it's the one and this is someone
who say this you taught this course many
times someone's going to get bitten by
it
I'll say it many times okay it's
uncomfortable when it happens
okay so this is now I can think about my
training data as a matrix
awesome
okay so now we have a bunch of notation
I've basically bored you to death with a
hundred different ways to write down
your data set but I haven't answered the
question that we actually cared about
which is how do I find something that's
good right how do I find an example
of something that's good all right so
now let's look at here so why do we
think this line is good you remember
this from how you fit it you think it's
good because it makes small errors right
like if it were all lying on the line
right on top of the line the distance
from any point to the line would be zero
and we think the line was pretty good if
we could kind of minimize those errors
okay and this is the error this is the
residual now for computational reasons
and historical reasons we'll look at the
squares of those residuals in just a
second okay don't worry too much about
that you can do everything I'm telling
you with the absolute value of the
things right you don't want to do the
signed value of them because what does a
negative error mean right you should pay
a penalty is the intuition whenever you
make an error
all right
so let's look at this all right so we're
going to look at our H and I'm now going
to write it sub Theta
J goes from 0 to D
Theta J of x j okay so now picking a
good model I can actually make some
sense for what do I want well I want
somehow that h of theta X is
approximately equal to the Y when X and
Y are paired right if X and Y come from
a new example you show me a new image
it's a kazak cat or not that label may
be opaque to me but it exists
I want my prediction to be close to that
y on average
or for house prices you give me a new
house I predict its price is as close as
possible I may not get the exact dollar
but it should be penalized a lot if I'm
off by a million dollars maybe but not
if I'm off by ten dollars right that's
kind of the the intuition here right so
how do I write that down
the idea is I'm going to look at this
function J which we're going to come to
a couple of different times
and it's this is that one half is just
normalization
I'm going to look at my data
and I'm going to say take my prediction
on the ice element
y i and square it okay now this is our
first example of a cost function and I
wrote it in a really weird way
but I want to come back to why I'm doing
it this way okay this is also called
least Square so you've probably seen
this
a bunch of times
and that's okay and if not don't worry
we'll go through it there's nothing
there's nothing mysterious okay so let's
unpack it so this thing here is the
prediction it says you give me a point x
i what's my prediction on x i some Y and
that says it should be close to whatever
the training set said why I was remember
what we're given we're given x i and y i
pairs that are together image cat house
information all of its description and
the price we should be close okay
we're penalized more for errors that are
far away I could give you a big song and
dance about why this is appropriate and
indeed there are lots of statistical
song and dances about it but really
we're doing it because it's easy to
compute everything that I'm going to do
you just want something that's kind of
sensible right like you should be
penalized more the more wrong your guess
is Right roughly speaking in this
example okay now
what does it mean to pick a good model
well our model is now determined
solely by those those Theta J's
right if we knew the Theta J is our
model would be completely determined
that was the trick I pulled on you and I
said oh we're gonna how are we going to
represent our hypothesis we're going to
represent it in this class that means
now we reduce from all the crazy
functions that you could have ever
dreamed up any computer program that you
could ever have written that was
functional to the class of functions
that are represented by these weights
the wild thing is
there's a lot of function you can
represent that way okay and we'll see
that over the over the course of the
class okay especially when you start to
get really high Dimensions Okay cool so
which one am I going to pick yeah please
do constantly awesome question yeah very
Advanced question so the question is hey
you wrote this one half there it seems
unnecessarily and potentially confusing
why would you pay the cost to do it and
the reason is when I take the derivative
in a minute it will cancel out make my
life easier okay but there's no and the
other point that you made is and I love
the way you said it this is exactly
right we don't care I wouldn't call it
that we care only about the gradient but
we only care about the minimizer for the
loss function so if your loss function
costs 10 or cost 100 doesn't matter what
you care about is what Theta minimizes
it you got that concept exactly right so
I hope that makes sense when we're
setting up the cost function in some
ways sometimes we give it an
interpretation almost a debug it to
understand what it's doing but really
all we care about is what is the Theta
when we minimize over all the thetas of
J Theta this is what we're solving for
right so we we basically want to solve
this J Theta now as we'll see in a
second
for linear functions we can do this for
more complicated sets of functions it's
not always clear that they're even you
know it exists a minimizer that we can
that we can reasonably find okay right
so there could be these wild functions
that take bumps and everything so I'll
draw one for you in a minute right when
we talk about solving it but for linear
functions what's amazing and why we
teach the normal things you can prove
what H Theta is in this example
wonderful Point okay but that's the
central thing we're going to set up
these costs so that we get a model out
we've restricted the class of what we're
looking at to something that's
relatively small where we can fit the
parameters then we just have to minimize
okay awesome right this is this this is
what I mean by optimization by the way
just solving this equation
okay I haven't told you how we're going
to solve it yet but hopefully this is
good now just for leading a little bit
ahead for the and also to kind of stall
in case anyone wants to ask a question
what we're eventually going to do is
we're going to replace this J with
increasingly complicated potentially
functions that we're going to look at
one for classification one for other
statistical models but we're going to do
almost everything that comes after this
part to all of those models so once we
kind of get it in this form where it's
like a prediction and some penalty for
how how poorly it's doing we may use
different cost functions everything that
comes next we'll be able to do for all
of them okay that's why we set up all
this kind of kind of elaborate notation
for like fitting a line
it is still by the way boggles my mind
how much machine learning you can do by
just fitting lines like just higher and
higher dimensional lines but we can talk
about that some other time
okay awesome
okay
all right
so how are we going to solve this now
there are many ways to solve this if
you've taken a linear algebra course
you're like oh I compute the normal
equations and then I'm done least Square
so your Matlab or numpy person you're
like oh I do you know least Square solve
or whatever it is backslash whatever you
want to do we're going to solve it in a
way that sets us up for the rest of
machine learning because machine
learning will deal in functions that
aren't quite as nice as linear
regression quite a bit and in fact the
trend has been when I like first got
into machine learning and Antiquity we
were all about what were called convex
or bowl shaped functions just roughly we
were really obsessed were we getting the
right Theta right we're like
statisticians like at Large Scale can we
get the right Theta is there one
individual Theta modern machine learning
done care we don't even know if we get
the right answer we don't even know how
there's a paper I was reading from
deepmind this morning that was like oh
you should run your models longer no one
noticed right how do we not know when to
run the models longer we don't that's
the world we live in so how does this
work so imagine we want to we want to
this is our cost function
okay now just as an aside I want to say
the linear function doesn't look like
that so don't think about the linear
function looks nice and bowl shaped Okay
the reason that's important as I was
just saying is a local minimum this is a
local minimum so is this so is this
roughly speaking is global when you're
convex that doesn't make sense to you
don't worry about it
okay
four convex we'll come back to that
point later in the course but I just
want to say like don't think of this
function I'm drawing here as what
happens with least squares we're just
optimizing A J for right now okay
all right so how are we going to do it
we're going to use a very simple
algorithm we're going to start with a
guess
which is going to be Theta 0. how did we
pick this gas
felt good
randomly
set it to zero all reasonable things to
do their entire machine learning papers
by the way written I've even written
some which I'm not sure if I should be
embarrassed or proud of that talk about
how you initialize various different
parts of the model okay
for us though it won't matter for our
least squares and some of the other
models we're studying because we'll be
able to get to the right solution
all right so now imagine for the moment
I found you a model
I found your initial model well it's
clearly from looking around imagine I'm
just looking I'm the point and I'm
looking clearly I can go down from here
right so the natural greedy heuristic is
compute the gradient what does the
gradient look like here it looks like
this oops I can make it do this fancier
okay you see that good I compute the
gradient
and then I I walk downhill
sound good right tells me to go downhill
from here right I'm at whatever shape
I'm at this gradient will also tell me
what to do now there's some problems
right just as an aside what if I were
right here oh it doesn't tell me what to
do but don't worry about that it's a
local maximum I'd be toast
but here tells me to go downhill
okay now once I go downhill how far do I
go
again feels good I pick a value it's
called a step size
so my next value is going to look like
this
t plus 1 is going to be defined to be
5T minus some Alpha
Theta
J Theta T now my notation is a little
bit weird here imagine it's one
dimensional for the second
okay
compute the gradient go in the opposite
direction
that's all that's going on this thing
here is called a learning rate
embarrassingly I think I've won awards
for papers that are about learning
rights but they are not very well set so
you just kind of pick a value for deep
learning people now have all kinds of
what they call adaptive optimizers if
you look in the literature about how to
set these values for you
um you don't want to set it too big or
too small there is a theory about how to
do it for linear things but don't worry
for you you just kind of pick a value
okay just imagine like what could go
wrong what happens if you pick it too
big well then you kind of shoot off over
here right you pick it too small then
you make little bumps like this right
you don't make enough progress
it's not too hard to think about what
what should happen here
and then what happens well I get a new
point
this is my Theta 1 and as suggestively
done here I iterate I compute the
gradient and I bounce down and then
hopefully I get closer
oh sorry that is just a this is my
notation uh for the gradient with
respect to Theta
this is a partial derivative with
respect to Theta right so imagine it's
one dimensional and I'm just setting up
for the fact that I'm going to use
multiple Dimensions it's literally just
a gradient with respect to Theta
the derivative in this case
now
now what I'll do is I'll compute that J
for all
zero to D characters
and that gives me my high dimensional
rule
okay
please
uh yeah so right now I've just shown it
I've just shown J as an abstract
function I haven't decomposed it as a
sum that's a great Point let's come back
to that in one minute
exactly what happens when we have a data
point it's going to be my next next line
other questions okay is it clear
so I did actually a fair amount of work
there
and tricked you just so you're clear I
went from one dimension to D plus one
Dimensions by just changing the sub
index
and did them all by themselves so make
sure that that sits okay with you right
please
yeah so how can we understand it on a
graph what do you mean by on a graph
like on this graph in particular
awesome yeah yeah so just imagine that
so the one-dimensional case carries what
you need to deal with so you're in a
particular basis right meaning you have
like Theta 1 Theta 2. so imagine I'm
standing in two dimensional space I can
look down one axis and then I have a
one-dimensional function then I have a
gradient there that gives me the vector
in this direction then imagine I turn 90
degrees orthogonally I look 90 degrees
there I get another one dimensional
function I compute its gradient now the
gradient is actually if you look at the
derivative it's actually the all those
vectors put together one after the other
in component
but that's exactly right yeah so yeah
but you're asking exactly the right
questions right so just picture it as
the tangent to the curve if that helps
you in high Dimensions if not don't
wonderful questions okay so what do I
hope that you understand here's some
rule you have the intuition that what
it's going to do is it's going to bounce
slowly downhill okay now if you start to
think about high dimensions and I think
this is why the question came starts to
get a little weird what does it mean in
high Dimensions you can imagine like
something that looks like a saddle if
you know like a saddle then you're like
oh gosh what's going to happen when I
get to the top of the saddle clearly I
can go off the sides and get a little
bit smaller right that would be good
maybe it goes down and stops but I can
get stuck on the top of the saddle too
and weirdly enough it's called the
saddle point don't don't worry
okay sound good
right we're not worrying about
convergence right notice this algorithm
has a very clear error mode here we
found what looks like the global minimum
but what if we started here
we would go bounce bounce bounce and
we'd find this one
now how do you stop this algorithm you
stop the algorithm when it's stop when
this update becomes too small okay and
you set that tolerance maybe you set it
to What's called the machine Precision
like 10 to the minus 6 16 where you set
it to you know 10 to the minus eight or
you want a quick solution you know 10 to
the minus three or something
the point is no matter what you do
you're going to get stuck here with a
with a descent method because it's going
to go downhill and get stuck here and
you're going to miss this much better
solution
that won't happen for linear regression
we won't talk about why at this exact
moment we can prove it in a little bit
but for things that are bowl shaped
every local minimum is a global uh
minimum then we're in good shape that's
why we cared so much about these things
10 12 years ago we care about them you
know occasionally now
less than we used to
okay
all right so let's compute some of those
some of some of those derivatives
getting back to the earlier asked
question which was hey what does this
mean for a sum
okay
all right so remember RJ had a very
specular form so we're going to compute
the partial derivative with respect to
some sub J of J Theta okay so this is
the the derivative here oops
the derivative with respect to the jth
component
okay now
we take the sum I goes from 1 to n
I'm going to put the one-half inside
because I can
and then this is linear
and we'll come back to what that means
in one second
okay I just did a little bit of work
here not much I just rewrote the
definition of j which is this sum
and then I took the the partial
derivative and I pushed it inside
because it's linear okay we should know
that gradients are linear
okay now when I do that I get something
actually fairly intuitive
and this makes my uh
you know heart sing
times
partial derivative Theta J
of x okay now this is I cancel the 2
with the one half back to the question
about kind of the cooking show
preparation and that is standard by the
way now look what I have here which is
kind of nice
this thing is basically the error but
it's signed tells me which way I'm
making a mistake you know kind of too
high or too low right that's all that
thing is this is the the misprediction
or the error
okay now I have the derivative
with respect to the underlying function
class now why did I bother to write it
out this way clearly I could have
skipped the step of doing this and
jumped right to the end but this is this
is going to be general for almost all
the models we care about that's why I
did this okay so what is it in a
specific situation we'll recall h of
theta of X was equal to Theta 0 x 0 plus
Theta 1 x 1 plus you know Theta 2 x 2
plus Computing the derivative of this
pretty easy
it's just
oops
Theta j h Theta of X is x j
right
please
superscript over X on the right
here
on the right here yes oh this should
have a superscript oh I'm so sorry great
catch
this is at that data point
wonderful catch thank you
I generalizable because your H is normal
equation or some trigonometry it could
be whatever you want all I care about is
this is the error times the derivative
with respect to that underlying model
this is a very basic version of like
what looks like a chain kind of rule and
we're going to use that like nobody's
business so if you didn't know the chain
rule before this class you will
definitely know it by the end because we
use it Non-Stop but yeah this is just
set up for that that's why it's
generalizable it's the error which is
totally generalizable for any model that
has to do with prediction times how you
compute the derivative like what's the
change of the underlying model we'll be
able to generalize that and in this case
it's just XJ
all right so now
right
getting back to this
what is our whole rule it looks like
this
Theta J Theta J T minus Alpha sum over
all the data answering the earlier
question at this point we're doing
what's called batch gradient which we'll
come back to in one second
minus y i
times
x i j now notice I'm going to try and do
some highlighting here I hope this is
okay for people to see and I apologize
if you're colorblind and this doesn't
doesn't help you too much but these are
the same
okay hopefully these are distinguishable
colors these J's and then the i's are
the other index that's going on and
these are the data points themselves
okay so I look at every data point and
I'm doing the jth component of each one
right now
by the magic of vector notation
here's what I can do
I just write this as this
H Theta
x i
this doesn't change
this is a vector equation
okay so this is basically looping over
all the J indices at once
if you're unfamiliar with Vector
notations one of the reasons I'm doing
this quickly is I will do it second hand
throughout the course it's not deep it's
not like it requires a lot of stuff just
requires a little bit of reps kind of
repeat on that please
same brand for
a wonderful question so Alpha you will
typically set for the for an iteration
right when you take a step you typically
you can change it across steps so one
thing is here I've said Alpha does not
depend on uh on T the iteration step but
in general it usually does you usually
Decay The Learning rate over time so
that's just what's done in practice
that's done for really good things what
you don't typically do is have Alpha
depend on the data points itself because
then it's kind of almost functioning
like a free parameter at least in
classical machine learning but in both
optimizers one of which was invented by
our own John duchy and other folks you
actually do change the alphas for every
different coordinate which was you know
I think his first paper was at a grad
and then out of Delta so people do
things like that that are a little bit
more sophisticated and why they do those
I'm happy to explain offline but right
now just think of alpha as a constant
like it's small enough that it's not
going to lead you too far astray like if
it were too big you jump too far and
maybe you could do a little bit better
but you know maybe not too much in fact
there's a very very basic rule which is
called with gradient descent rule is is
actually very widely used very very
widely used with just one alpha
wonderful question and those are the
right questions to ask like how does
this parameter depend on what's around
it start thinking like that as you go
through the course that's really really
helpful to understand
okay so far so good so at this point we
know how to fit a line which doesn't
feel like a huge accomplishment maybe
but I think it's pretty cool
um and we fit it in this kind of
obfuscated General way that's going to
allow us to do more models I claim but
I'll verify that in two classes
this vector equation here is just
showing you like all the things that we
computed this is specific to the earlier
point to the line right this is this
gradient here
is this guy those are the same that's
why this model popped out
we'll come back to that in a minute
okay now a topic that is practically
quite important for machine learning is
and it was hinted at earlier is and I'll
copy this equation
is
what do we you know do in practice so
one thing that we may not like about
this equation is this thing is huge in
modern machine learning we'll often look
at data sets that have millions or
billions of points right well it's not
uncommon to run models where you're like
every sentence that has been emitted on
the web in the last 10 years is a
training example or every token right
every every word
and would be just enormous right at that
point it'd just be a huge thing so even
doing one pass over your data is
potentially too much okay that's a
really extreme and crazy version of that
uh that's a really extreme and crazy
version of that but you can also Imagine
situations where you're looking at
hundreds or thousands of images and you
potentially want to look at fewer so
we'll come to how we do that in a second
sorry yeah
oh it's t and t plus one it's the it's
these are the steps remember we started
at Theta zero so superscript uh zero was
our initial guess here
and then we moved from one to two to
three to four and so this is just the
recursive rule that takes you from Theta
T to Theta t plus one
e is just whatever
exactly so you just imagine it as a it's
a it's a it's a you know kind of
recursive way to specify where at
particular T and here's how we evolve to
t plus one exactly right you got it
perfectly
exactly right so Theta T when we go back
to here oops sorry I hope that's not
dizzy and I always throw a way to skip
without making you sick is this Vector
it's just a particular instantiation of
those vectors one for every of the D
plus one components
please
stuff
yeah so we will take steps as I said
until we converge typically or we can
take a fixed number of steps I'm eliding
that because for this particular problem
I can kind of give you a rule of thumb I
can point you out a paper that tells you
how to set Alpha in general for machine
learning as I was kind of very obliquely
referring to we don't actually know uh
how to tell that we've converged and
part of the reason is
when if you knew your model was this
nice bowl shaped then you could actually
prove that the closer you get to the
optimum the smaller your gradient is
getting and you can predict kind of how
far away you're going to be basic for A
Nice Class of functions for nastier
functions and the ones that we're going
to care about more you can't do that so
it doesn't make sense to say that you
found the right answer and so I don't
emphasize that for these models I can
give you a beautiful story happy to type
it up online and tell you but but in
general for machine learning honestly we
just like run it till it feels good like
oh the curve stopped it stopped getting
better and that was this deep mine paper
that said hey for these really large 280
billion parameter models so their their
Theta has 280 billion parameters in it
they're like we didn't run it long
enough if we kept running it it was
better and like everyone who works in
machine learning for long enough in the
last five years has a situation where
they forgot they were training a model
hopefully like you're not paying for it
on you know AWS or gcp or something and
then you come back like a week later and
it's doing better than you thought and
that is a very strange situation so I
don't have a great rule for this for
your projects it will be clearer I'm
telling you the real stuff though
[Music]
so we will only use it in the forward
direction of going T to t plus one but
you know you could imagine that it's
reversible if you wanted
oh wonderful question yeah yeah so in
the sense that like if you shoot past
let's go back here
so if you're here and you shoot past
your step is kind of too big for the
gradient you kind of trust it too much
then in the next iteration the gradient
will point in this direction right and
so you'll step back so it will actually
have kind of this ping pong and that's
actually a you actually want that to
happen it turns out the optimal rate I
mean I can bore you with this for days
the optimal rate is actually when you're
doing that skipping for for whatever
reason yeah but it's more intuitive for
people to roll down the hill yeah
wonderful point you got it exactly right
please uh so is it possible for the
update to be zero even if H Theta of x i
is not necessarily
yeah so
um so it's not possible for it to be
exactly zero everywhere but it's
possible to have gradients that are not
giving you any information
wonderful question absolutely wonderful
question it's because it's a linear
system right so that's not full rank for
the linear algebra nerds wonderful
question
say you have like
um or something right but you flip it so
Theta zero is equal to zero but on the
other side when you only get the local
minimum over there and not the actual
like exactly right yeah and that's what
I'm saying like uh we used to worry
about that quite a bit now we just say
it's good
I wish I could tell you something better
than that but we'll get into why that's
true but yeah when your function is in a
good class and good here formally means
like convex and bounded in some way then
you will provably get to the right
solution we'll talk about those
conditions later I'm just the reason I
de-emphasize them now is because modern
machine learning actually works on
functions that look like this not on the
other class of functions and so that's
less important uh for students and then
you know you would rightly say like you
told me all this stuff I memorized all
these conditions and then I got into the
workforce I'm like none of them worked
and no one uses them like yeah that's
true but it's you're exactly right and
so people worry about initialization
where do you start so that you're kind
of guaranteed to get a good model in
fact there were a couple of awesome
Theory results and one from my group one
from 10 news that said for certain class
of these nasty non-convex models if you
initialize in a particular way you would
be guaranteed to get the right answer
actually I'll show you one in week 11 a
simple version of that where if you
initialize cleverly there's not a unique
answer but you'll get the right one
every time yeah or sorry class 11 not
week 11. yeah
yeah people try random initialization
the problem is this model the trend is
for models to be really expensive so you
run huge models so any one run could
cost a couple million dollars like I was
looking at the Amazon's gpt3 service
they cost like six million dollars a
month to run so like you know do you
want to try to run it multiple times
like if you got money go ahead but you
kind of want to try and do other tricks
people used to do a lot more random
restarting now we've kind of it's really
sad to say this is the state but we've
kind of absolved like flexonomies like
like if you train these models you kind
of know uh you know what are the right
parameters and what is everybody else
using and not everyone tries and
explores everything let alone how long
you tune it you know what optimizers you
use we kind of all use the same stuff
um but we don't have great formal
justification for it maybe I'm exposing
too much it's not as bad as it sounds it
there's like there actually are
principles in this area I'm just like
telling you the plates that are broken
because they're more interesting to me
and
we're going to come back to that so the
the solution is like do I wanna there's
a phenomenon that a lot of people know
about in machine learning which is if I
take my uh my model and I exactly fit my
training data maybe it won't generalize
well like it'll be it'll fit to some
error some noise in the data and this is
roughly overfitting we cover that in
lecture 10. in lecture 10 at least when
I taught it last I also talked about
something which is in modern machine
learning we realized that actually
sometimes that concern is overstated for
some models there's a wonderful paper by
Misha Belkin that said you can actually
interpolate perfectly fit your data and
optimally generalize for some classes
and models so that trade-off isn't as
clear for modern models as it was for
old models may I just stop telling you
about this stuff but yes in general
overfitting is a problem you can overfit
a model and believe your training data
too much
but it's this area is fascinating I can
obviously rant about it for for weeks so
wonderful questions
yeah yeah this is absolutely great okay
so what do I want to tell you so I don't
want to tell you normal equations I
thought that was pretty clear from the
from the beginning so you can read about
those if you want I'll type up notes
Andrew's notes are great on this point
but I do want to tell you this one
little bit with my last couple of
minutes about batch versus stochastic
mini batch because this is it actually
is is relevant and useful
okay so when we last left off we were
looking at this equation and when you
notice this problem that n was really
big and I just hopefully told you like n
is really big and so is D the number of
parameters is really big so this is
expensive I wouldn't want to look at all
of my training Data before I took my
first step because probably my initial
guess is not that good that's why I'm
training a model like if my if randomly
initializing the model which is
something people try to do gave me good
predictions I just used that so
obviously I want to take as many steps
as I can so here's what I'll do
I use mini batches so what does mini
batching do okay I won't get too formal
but basically what I'll do is I'll
select sum B let's say at random
okay I'm being vague here what random
means I wrote a bunch of papers about
this you can either pick uh you know
randomly select them or you can Shuffle
the order and in conventional machine
learning we Shuffle the order for a
variety of reasons and then I pick B
items so B is going to be much smaller
than n
okay
all right and then I update
I'll call it I'm going to call it this
because this made me make it more clear
I equals one and or actually I'm going
to write it a little bit Strangely I
apologize for this notation notation is
better in my notes but I want to write
it this way because it's easier to say
x i
y i that makes it more clear what's
going on I hope okay what's going on so
I select a bunch of indexes B
and then I just compute my estimate of
the gradient over them
okay
I could even pick B to be size one just
pick a single point if someone was
alluding to earlier and take a step now
what are the obvious trade-offs here on
one hand if I pick a step that step is
really fast right if I pick a single
element it's super fast to compute
relative to looking at the entire data
set but it's going to be noisy it's
going to have low quality I may not have
enough information to step in the
direction I want to go
on the other hand if I look at the whole
data set it's going to be super accurate
about what the gradient is in fact I'll
compute it exactly up to numerical
issues
but it's super slow
now what people do is they tend to pick
batches that are on the smaller side
right and you pick them kind of as big
as you can tolerate and I won't go into
the reasons for this underlying Hardware
happy to answer questions about it but
basically you pick batches that are kind
of as many as you can get for free
Modern Hardware Works kind of in
parallel so you'll grab and look at like
128 examples there's not much you know
more expensive than looking at one okay
on a modern kind of platform
now I'm using these noisy kinds of
proxies and you may think am I still
guaranteed to converge and the answer is
effectively yes and under really really
uh harsh conditions in fact yeah I'm
very proud of something that my first
PhD student I and and collaborators Ben
Rector and Steve Wright wrote about this
paper called Hog Wild which is very
stupid has an exclamation point but also
got a 10-year test of time award for
saying that you can basically run these
things in the craziest possible ways and
they still converge these kind of
stochastic sampling regimes okay I won't
go into details about that my point is
like this thing is actually fairly
robust this kind of take a bunch of
error estimates and step them and in
fact almost all modern machine learning
is geared towards what's called mini
batching if you download pytorch or
jacks or tensorflow or whatever you're
using odds are it has native support to
give you mini batches okay and that is
basically just taking in oops taking an
estimate
this piece here
and using that noisy estimate and why
might that make sense well imagine your
data set contains a bunch of near copies
if your data set contained all copies
then you would just be reading the same
example and getting no information right
If instead you are sampling that same
example you would go you know
potentially unboundedly faster and if
you think about like what we're looking
at when I told you images like the
images on my phone for my daughter there
are a lot of pictures of my daughters a
lot okay I'm a regular dad I take lots
of pictures so that means there's a lot
of density and so machine learning
operates in these regimes where you have
huge dense repeated amounts of data okay
all right
so this is going to come back we're
going to see this next time we're going
to see it in particular when we start to
look at various different
um
um loss functions we're going to
generalize How We Do prediction to
classification next time and then to a
huge class of statistical models called
exponential family models to go back to
the top I skipped just to make sure you
know what's here and what I skipped we
went through the basic definitions we
saw how to fit a line we went through
batch and stochastic gradient Descent of
how to solve the underlying model we set
up a bunch of notation this is going to
be one of the drier classes where I'm
just like writing out all the bits of
notation and we saw how to solve them
those will all carry over to our next
brand of models the normal equations if
you run into problems blame me I'm happy
to take a look through them they're
relatively straightforward and the notes
are pretty good but I'll look at Ed if
you run into any problems there and
happy to answer questions
with that thank you so much time for
your time and tension and I hope to see
some of you on Monday